Hank is Hank somebody from a king of the
hill is that somebody from your life
yeah that's about two or three people
um and can you say their name and have
you said their name uh probably
one of them I think knows who he is
because I ran into his son but uh you
told his son and I actually can't
remember his name
um when uh when Jessica and I lived in
our first house outside of Dallas a
place called Richardson
we had these neighbors and they were
just these four Dudes were always out
there drinking beers in the alley you
entered your driveway Through the Alley
and uh you know I was a musician and a
storm had come through and knocked down
a section of my fence and so I'm not
really such a handyman you know but I'm
out there trying to fix it and I'm like
pounding a nail in and I see this guy
and he's like eyeballing me like I'm
doing it wrong and he comes over and he
goes yeah that's not going to work
you're going to have to take that post
out it's rotted and I said oh okay then
the other guy comes in this guy uh Ron
comes over he's like
yeah I got some concrete uh and then the
other guy and and after like I just
woken up like a guy comes over the
wheelbarrow another guy has concrete and
hose and and this this guy he goes well
I've got couple fence posts in my garage
like he already had him this guy had I
remember asking him about he's talking
about a rototiller and he had two
rototillers and he's got just a normal
size like the size room no it's not it's
like a little
but then he comes and after a while like
they're all like pouring concrete and
running a string between I realize like
I'm kind of useless here and I went back
inside and Jessica was there like
looking out the window like what's going
on out there they're putting up a new
fence for us I guess oh that's fantastic
and then finally like I come out and
they're done and he's telling me like
like the thing to do like it's like uh
well you put up these palings and you
leave a two inch Gap because them
termites will get in there and then I
said okay so then I'm I go get some
nails and I start pounding them in I see
them
like oh [ __ ] here he comes he's like
him's the wrong kind of nails
and then he goes gets his nails and come
and then he starts like that it's
hysterical and once we looked out the
peephole and the next door neighbor was
edging my lawn with it with his weed
whacker because I'd done it wrong can
you imagine if you left the drapes open
in your bedroom
that's not how you do it usually if you
just take her from the back I can do it
I gotta oh that ain't going to work
give her a call that's sort of the
beginnings of King of the Hill was but
they're all that's I think what it hits
us is they're not just funny shows
they're real and even if they're
animated they are so steeped in reality
foreign
[Music]